في اجواء الحرب في اوكرانيا وتداعياتها
فقد اكد البيت الابيض انا واشنطن ستواصل
دعم فرض حد اقصى لسعر النفط الروسي على
امل ان يحدث ذلك من قدره الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمر بوتن على تمويل الحرب على
اوكرانيا في حين نقلت صحيفه وسط جورنال عن
مصادر مطلعه ان الولايات المتحده وحلفاءها
يسعون الى ابراهيم اتفاق لتحديد سقف اعلى
لاسعار النفط الروسيه غدا الاربعاء واضافه
المصادر ان مجموعه السبعه والاتحاد
سقفا لسعر النفط الروسيه عندها 60 دولارا
للبرميل وبالحسب الصحيفه الامريكيه فانه
بموجب العقوبات همم ستمتني يعود ولو
مجموعه السبعه والاتحاد الاوروبي
واستراليا عن تقديم الخدمات البحريه
لشحنات النفط الروسي ما لم يتم بيعها باقل
من الحد الاقصى الموحدد